how's it going bros my name is papa
welcome to san said ever dread I would
like to share players put apply how does
the game know my name connect I'm
looking at you that is not how I oh God
that's how I look like everyone knows I
am a ginger yuk yeah Wow and everything
the ginger with dreadlocks before and I
never wanted to either thanks
you can enable vulgarity filter no
thanks I'm good I'm really excited about
this game uh let's see if it's God ah
not so near my face please how can that
badass be totally screwed
I can I can benchmark that [ __ ] with my
pinky finger and here we are I like the
skin colored shirt makes it for extra
sexiness dodge roll that roll don't slap
me alright whoa I can [ __ ] flying
[ __ ] I can bounce and what get across
the street well that was fun if you like
bouncing you'll love this game whoa [ __ ]
a lot bouncing
grind along wires whoo
I like it I like this like that like
this dislike that whoo it's a beautiful
moaning ah heavy ah wonderful
nope hahahaha ah [ __ ]
nope there we go
I did the trick wasn't that wonderful
enter a little apartment damn it
[ __ ] don't be scared bro I'm here I'm
[ __ ] for work
smells like Edgar's butthole
no damn and then under grind how the
[ __ ] do you underground doesn't sound
very Christian while grinding on a wire
flip between grind and none okay
convenient slow motion thank you I'll
take it
oh hey I knew I couldn't trust a guy in
a blue shirt oh wait come on sexism in
games all right it's time whoa what am I
even going damn Thor is on fire
Oh how does how does that even it's
awesome I'm shooting him sure he's
shooting him Hey
well he's stood in front of me I didn't
try to stop protip if you don't want to
die like don't stand in front of me that
be uh yet
I may have died now we're fine I'm fine
I knew it somehow I'm fine I like his
arm it's what happens when you have too
much you got to balance it out between
both I'm just saying it's giving you
burst tips don't want to look like that
guy to you all right that's cool I like
this game so far it's really [ __ ]
weird and I love bouncing so this is
like the best thing ever baby if you buy
with me he laughs got a lot with a
splattering [ __ ] you're leaving the
missionary I don't tell me what to do
get home get home or die trying
there we are all right now we can go
home
finally huh
let's fight with both hands we don't
look like that guy
yes a beer that's the first thing you do
that's the only thing
as awesome I've no idea what's going on
I love it
don't be late Oh No
kind of futuristic setting is this this
is three hours earlier
I am oh I get it
it's dead rat [ __ ] No
thora doesn't like his job dorwan smash
it
overcharge makes them tiny bit little
Swedish Vikings ginger Vikings sorry I
get it it all makes sense
your own spoons come on Thor you can
enjoy life can you the word just wants
to play his own video game what the [ __ ]
what is that don't throw up on the door
aw jeez
convenient to play scrub I am run tower
stupid so stupid
really
schrödinger's we might what does it say
get oh don't tell me what to do train
[ __ ] haha go oh this style of this game
it's [ __ ] awesome
and I got my very first Xbox one
achievement awesome and now I get to
customize store it's always like I'm
replaying whatever the hell I was doing
alright Thor how do you want to look now
we already decided for the dreadlocks
didn't we well it does look very fab no
stick with the dreadlocks and that's
final
door is ready Thor is a dame hahaha so
beautiful so kawaii Squatch berries
knows my favorites
Thor had plenty of beer what else what
do you look inside its vegetable
damnit
Walter master of badassery no that's
stored you got it all wrong
Jesus is that Santa cause space Santa
Claus or something must be interview oh
wow
what happened guy just saved your ass
this is exhausting still left in the
city but not for long
take this I'm a crowbar thank you
the odd okay got it
um smack my [ __ ] up
goddamn their disgust oh god that's
gross three more okay I can do that
that's three that's four and this one's
for four because it rhymes at Stanley
the basketball court go to the
basketball courts alright damn
so are you cray cray I wanted to his
skirt to like go up but this game is
awesome
what do I do now I'm here
what's up sandy coast damn right it's a
test I met other survive more trouble
and they were worth that dead body over
there that one of them hey dead guy
what am I in for here break open that
crate pick up the gun
what now switch to your new gun how do I
do that how do I do that got it
that was the test what the [ __ ] is that
wait here what what idea get ready to
shoot some OD okay
OD am i shooting lp's at them mana waste
of ghetto in overcharge cause their
endocrine systems to go into overdrive
I'm gonna throw some overcharge onto the
court get ready for the real test okay
what the fudge cake is going out
addicted to that stuff
they'll be here quick here they come
hi I'm sandy who thought like hey we
have some LPS let's make a gun out of it
cuz why the [ __ ] not a and the next to
grind along the wedges okay alright
that's one dead Opie wait what was your
name [ __ ]
alright and grinding on my in my
beautiful shorts
damnit
what that [ __ ] are they doing
come at me brah
get up on that what be it don't tell me
what to do come on damn Thor is a Jonah
lore that was a joke tried very hard the
National Guard news helicopters wake up
kid
Cisco controls everything can't we just
call for help or something it's not that
easy it's not the Viking Way
communications outside the city but I
have a plan
visco did this not on purpose but
they're doing a hell of a job covering
it up rest of the world thinks we're all
dead from some kind of virus come on
gotta keep moving ah yeah I love that
Jetson radio feel that's one of my
favorite games I'm pretty biased to this
but it's cool yeah [ __ ] wonder how we
did that all right what do we got
this here is two head jack he makes
weapons you sell me short buddy I'm a
master craftsman
I make unbelievable [ __ ] unbelievable
[ __ ] alright we'll see about that
it's all that weapons acid sprinkler
nice you want more weapons you'll come
back with more overcharge deal
come on I want you to meet forward why
the [ __ ] is Floyd
all right hots up Lloyd what it's flowy
doing our new partner well alright
my name is Floyd I don't believe him
absent might and signed it what do
intruders oh now that's no bueno
also kind of Borderlands feel alright
we're gonna have to take care of them no
problem
I do this [ __ ] every day literally it's
kind of my job okay
shoot first okay oh Jesus I don't think
that's how physics works
hahaha use the wire why you just [ __ ]
shoot them alright fine
it's kind of harder to shoot them now
there we go just oh my god this is too
hard
never guy
I got there so many Abigail it's one
here no wow yeah yeah barely I have to
aim at them exhausted come on back all
right we're going back don't worry it's
going back
conveniently plays wired I wish you
could do tricks on them that'd be
awesome
nailed it I'm gonna head out to the
overpass but I should at work okay
I could use some more supplies head on
down to the tracks I'll explain on the
way by myself
hey I know there's some look at it you
tell yourself you gonna have a good time
you'll have a good time
am i right you're right those
[ __ ] Oni will tear you apart be
careful all right
far out camping what what did I just say
all right press can I have that episode
there if you enjoyed this and want to
see more hit that like button
I really appreciate breasts um if I get
enough support I'll I'll keep playing
I'll leave this one up to you Bruce and
that's all for me for now thank you for
watching and that's always stay awesome
bro